regarde carlos montrent leur voilà on va
avoir des grands tissus comme ça les
filles hockey et puis on va les découper
on va les coudre et puis on va faire des
sacs avec pas question de gâcher le
moindre bout de tissu ici à les adh de
morteau on donne une seconde vie aux
affiches de musée objectif créer des
sacs originaux une oeuvre d'art en
quelque sorte parce qu'on va faire ça
qu'on va aller on va les épingles et là
on n'est pas déçu ouais un exercice de
précision et de concentration pour ces
travailleurs déficients mentaux
aline leurs éducatrices garde un oeil
sur leur travail
s'il faut qu'ils soient hyper droit
ouais ça marche on reste le long 1
ok c'est bien j'écoute du tout dans tout
le long j'ai coupé à jouer comme pour
faire ça ça invite à travailler sur la
précision la concentration la
coordination aussi et puis et puis à la
fin ça donne quand même un travail qui
est plutôt au beau et valorisant pour
eux un travail qui s'exposent ensuite à
la boutique du musée du temps de
besançon c'est d'ici que proviennent les
affiches
le musée a mis en place ce partenariat
il y a un an
c'est l'occasion effectivement de ne pas
gâcher de de valoriser des supports qui
n'ont pas dû plus d'utilité est épié
pour le public c'est aussi le moyen de
garder un souvenir de nos expositions
les sacs sont vendus 10 euros l'unité
l'intégralité des bénéfices est reversée
à les actes de morteau